Nous sommes en train de considérer les chapitres 6 de notre confession de foi
qui traite de la chute de l'homme, les péchés et son châtiment.
Il y a trois aspects importants à considérer sur cette doctrine liée à la notion du péché et de la chute.
Donc c'est la chute en elle-même, les contextes historiques
et la structure de ces pactes que Dieu avait établis avec Adam, les représentants de toute l'humanité.
Et donc comment on a échoué de cette condition qui était une condition des perfections originales.
Il y a beaucoup de mystères qui restent dans la doctrine et qui traitent non seulement de la chute
mais aussi du péché dans son origine, du péché par rapport à sa nature
et notamment les châtiments ou les résultats ou les conséquences du péché qui marquent l'histoire de l'humanité.
Donc ce qu'on a fait avant de porter une considération doctrinaire
et pourquoi c'est important d'arriver à la considération doctrinaire
c'est car ces événements qui ont eu lieu
ils ont eu lieu de manière très spontanée, très immédiate.
Ça a touché à notre nature.
Au départ, on avait une obéissance naturelle envers Dieu
et Dieu a établi un pacte en nous donnant l'opportunité d'atteindre une position
même si elle était déjà parfaite en soi
et c'était une perfection séminale
qui pourrait encore se développer à un état encore plus élevé
et de rendre cette condition éternelle.
Donc il y avait une obéissance entre guillemets automatique ou naturelle
mais Dieu nous a donné un privilège de volontairement nous soumettre à sa loi, à sa volonté
et par cet osage original du seul moment où on avait un vrai libre-arbitre
on a échoué.
Et donc on a raté cette opportunité de rendre notre condition parfaite, encore plus parfaite et éternelle.
Mais comme cela a été aussi un plan de Dieu qui n'a pas été frustré par notre condition,
Dieu a permis que cela arrive afin de faire usage de notre chute
pour nous conduire à cette position encore plus élevée
à travers un moyen encore plus élevé qui révèle davantage la gloire des dieux,
c'est-à-dire à travers Jésus-Christ.
Et donc, dans la considération de la chute,
nous sommes devant un récit historique
qui démontre comment les choses se sont déroulées de manière très naturelle,
des résultats immédiats de la chute,
on peut dire comme ça,
la honte,
les conséquences qu'on pourrait dire naturelles
de cette rébellion contre Dieu.
Par contre, Dieu arrive pour porter non seulement un jugement formel,
mais à travers ces jugements formels,
Dieu est en train de nous donner des structures doctrinales,
des structures en termes de compréhension
de la manière de Dieu
de traiter avec l'humanité,
la formalité de toutes ces choses,
car nous ne sommes pas qu'en train de voir une manifestation
des corruptions.
ou un simple manque des droitures ou d'obéissance.
On est devant la transgression d'une loi
qui a été révélée
par ces pactes envers les arbres.
Et Adam, donc, a eu une position
qui n'était pas tout simplement
les premiers êtres humains.
Et comme il a été corrompu,
toute sa descendance sera corrompue.
On était devant quelqu'un qui a été placé
comme un représentant légal et fédéral
de toute l'humanité.
Et donc, sa transgression est là,
ou les péchés commis par Adam,
elle a un élément formel,
légal,
qui va au-delà, quelque part,
de cette corruption tout simplement naturelle.
Et pourquoi c'est important
de comprendre la chute
de manière formelle
ou de manière doctrinale,
c'est car c'est par là
que nous allons avoir les bases
pour comprendre pourquoi Dieu a pu
développer son plan de rédemption,
pourquoi Christ a été en train de régler
un problème de transgression
devant un tribunal cosmique à la croix,
et pourquoi Dieu peut le justifier justement,
car il était en train de traiter
les problèmes du péché de l'humanité
de manière très formelle aussi.
Et donc, il y a cet abordage
envers la narrative historique de Genèse
où j'espère qu'aujourd'hui,
on soit de plus en plus convaincu
que nous ne pouvons pas jouer
avec l'historicité de la chute.
car déjà, à nouveau,
de manière très intuitive,
en respirant l'atmosphère
de récits bibliques,
nous pouvons déjà avoir compris
de quelle manière la tentation
frappe à notre porte,
de quelle manière la séduction
de Satan et les tentations
de la chair nous conduisent au péché,
de quelle manière la nature du péché
s'est manifestée dans nos vies.
Et on a plein d'apprentissages
à partir de ces récits
qui semblent être très simples,
très concis,
et qui certains, dans le jour,
veulent même faire face
comme si c'était mythologique,
symbolique.
Mais la réalité,
c'est que les plus on étudie
ces textes si simples,
les plus on comprend
la précision du diagnostic biblique
par rapport à notre condition,
mais plus que ça.
On est devant quelque chose
que Dieu a révélé
de manière suffisante,
qu'il est Saint-Esprit enregistré
pour que l'enregistrement
soit littéral,
car Dieu était déjà,
avec Genèse 1 à 3,
en train d'établir
la raison d'être
de toute la Bible,
de toute la révélation
de la manière par laquelle
Dieu doit nous délivrer.
Si nous mettons en question
la littéralité,
l'historicité de Genèse,
on doit mettre en question
l'ensemble de la révélation biblique
qui est une réponse
à ces bases
que nous trouverons déjà
en Genèse.
Et donc,
non seulement les auteurs bibliques
traitent de manière littérale,
mais même la compréhension
de l'Évangile
dépend quelque part.
Quand on arrive par exemple
à Romain 5
qu'on va considérer aujourd'hui,
c'est l'apôtre Paul
qui va présenter
Christ comme les nouvelles Adam
pour porter la solution
qui a été promise déjà à elle.
Donc,
ce qu'on a déjà fait,
c'était de faire un traitement
par une exposition biblique,
c'est-à-dire
on s'est plongé
dans les passages principaux
à propos de la chute
du péché original
et de ses conséquences.
La seule chose
qui nous a manqué
de considérer
avant de passer
à l'exposition doctrinale,
c'était de considérer
ces prénonces
de l'Évangile
qui sont déjà présents
de manière très structurée
et qui sont déjà
aussi manifestées
dans cette relation
d'impact des grâces
qui Dieu établit
avec Adam
après la chute.
Donc,
pendant que Dieu
est en train
de communiquer
les jugements,
les condamnations,
il est en train
de pouvoir
des éléments
qui nous donnent déjà
des indices
quelque part
implicites
mais aussi
des indices
explicites
par rapport
à la manière
dont lui-même
va s'occuper
de souffrir
la peine
de nos péchés
et pour voir
l'essai en Jésus
qui viendra.
C'est ce qu'on appelle
les proto-évangiles
et donc
quand on considère
les résultats
de la chute
par la confession,
on est plutôt concentré
par rapport
aux effets
du péché
et de sa condamnation
sur toute l'humanité.
Mais,
c'est important
de finir
cette considération
des expositions bibliques
du traitement direct
du texte
avec ces remarques
car ça faisait partie
aussi
du résultat
du péché
et de la condamnation
que Dieu
vienne apporter
son juste jugement
avec la communication
d'une mesure
des grâces
fondamentales.
Et donc,
quelque part,
c'est ici
que nous trouvons
les débuts
de l'établissement
de ce qu'on appelle
l'alliance
des grâces.
Cette promesse
que Dieu va faire
pour nous sauver
lorsqu'on ne méritait
rien à part
la condamnation totale
à ce moment-là.
Et donc,
verset 15,
c'est là
qu'on voit
la promesse
du proto-évangile
où les premiers
évangiles proclamés,
Dieu dit à la femme,
pardon,
au serpent,
pendant la condamnation
du serpent,
je mettrai l'illimitié
entre toi et la femme,
entre ta postérité
et sa postérité,
celle-ci t'écrasera
la tête
et tu lui blesseras
l'étalon.
Donc,
il y a un aspect
très sanguillé
par rapport
à cette sémence
qui viendra,
ces descendants
qui viendra
de la femme.
Nous savons très clairement
par la suite
de la révélation
progressive des dieux
de quelle manière
Christ est venu,
Christ a écrasé
la tête du serpent
et de quelle manière
il a eu
son talon blessé.
La mort du Christ
représente véritablement
ses talons blessés
et nous voyons
de quelle manière,
donc particulièrement
une étape importante,
c'était
la tentation
du Christ
qu'on a vu déjà
aussi dans cette série
d'études.
Et de quelle manière
la tentation
du Christ
au désert,
c'était
une reproduction
avec des circonstances
encore plus difficiles
à résister
à la tentation,
mais des parallèles
très explicites
entre la tentation
d'Adam,
les premiers Adam,
et les Christ,
les deuxièmes Adam.
Mais,
c'était notamment
la croix
qui a réussi
à avoir
cette victoire
totale,
pas contre
les droits
de Satan
de nous dominer,
mais c'est contre
les rôles
d'accusateurs
de Satan
envers ceux,
envers qui
Dieu va faire grâce
par les saluts.
Car l'accusateur,
c'est comme s'il disait
constamment devant Dieu,
tu ne peux pas
les sauver
ou les faire du bien
car ils sont
injustes comme moi,
ils sont rebelles
comme moi,
ils sont transgresseurs
comme moi.
et donc Dieu doit
se justifier
devant
son propre
paramètre
de justice
afin
de pouvoir
utiliser
cette généreuse
libéralité,
cette libre grâce
qui est
généreusement
déversée sur nous,
notamment dans
la nouvelle alliance
après que Christ
justifie tout
à la croix.
Ok ?
Et donc là,
on voit de manière
très claire,
c'est à ce moment-là
que l'apôtre Paul
va dire
aux Éphésiens
qu'il a
exposé
à l'ignonymie,
à l'espectacle
tous les anges,
les autorités célestes
donc rébelles,
les démons
par la croix,
par la manière
dont il nous a justifiés
à la croix.
Il les a exposés
à l'espectacle.
Ils n'ont plus
aucune
on va dire
entre guillemets
autorité
contre nous
car Christ
il a pu inaugurer
la nouvelle alliance
en ayant
accompli cette promesse.
Et donc,
c'est lui qui est venu
pour écraser
la tête du serpent
et avoir
son talon blessé.
Au verset 20,
nous voyons
une expression
des fois
même si ce n'est
pas très explicite
mais c'est clairement
dans la direction
de la promesse
qu'il a donnée.
Donc,
au départ,
lorsqu'il ne se sentait
pas complet
et que Dieu
lui donne la femme,
il va appeler
la femme,
lui qui était
les mâles,
Isch,
il va appeler
la femme,
Isch.
OK ?
Et donc là,
il va mettre
l'emphase
plutôt sur cet aspect
de la femme
de compléter l'homme.
Par contre,
Dieu avait déjà
donné
cet ordre,
en fait,
des multiplications,
etc.
et c'est notamment
sur cette promesse
qu'un descendant
viendra
pour régler
cette inimitié
entre les descendants
de ses parents
et les descendants
de la promesse
et donc Adam
va se diriger
vers sa femme
et va lui donner
un nouveau nom.
Elle n'est plus
femme,
maintenant elle est
mère,
elle est Ève
et donc ça va
concentrer
la foi
d'Adam
dans la direction
de la promesse
de Dieu.
Donc Paul va revenir
sur ce point
en disant
que la femme
a été préservée
et préservée
par sa mission
des mères
et notamment
par le fait
que Dieu a donné
aux femmes
les privilèges
que les saveurs
viennent
à travers
sa contribution,
sa maternité
et donc on voit
de manière très claire
la beauté
de cette promesse
qui insiste
sur cet espoir,
cette dignité
même si la femme
souffrirait
surtout
dans cette mission
qui apporte
sa plus grande
dignité,
être mère
quelque part,
avec douleur
tu vas enfanter,
en même temps
la promesse
que les Messies
viendraient
à travers
la maternité,
elle est là
pour restaurer
aussi
cette appréciation.
Et donc on voit
par là
cet autre aspect
des manifestations
des fois
et d'espoir
pour l'humanité
dans cet épisode.
Au verset 21,
on voit encore
plus des éléments
qui dirigent
nos yeux
et nos attentes
envers
cette structure
fédérale
quelque part,
les substitutions
qu'on verra.
Donc l'éternel
Dieu dit,
pardon,
l'éternel Dieu
fit à Adam
et à sa femme
des habits
des peaux
et il les a
revêtis.
Donc il y a
ce langage
biblique très récurrent
de la manière
dont Dieu
va nous revêtir
lui-même
de sa droiture.
Donc lorsqu'il nous
semble dans
le Nouveau Testament
à plusieurs reprises,
nous sommes appelés
à nous dépouiller
du vieil homme
pour nous revêtir
du Christ,
de l'homme nouveau.
Ok ?
Et donc Adam
et Ève
au moment
de leur péché,
ils ont cherché
à se vêtir
des feuilles.
Ils étaient
coupabilisés,
ils avaient honte
et ils se sont
revêtis des feux.
Ça ne suffit pas.
L'homme
ne peut jamais
pouvoir
sa manière
de se couvrir
de ses péchés
devant Dieu.
Et donc ce qu'on va
retrouver ici,
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui va,
et d'ailleurs
c'est important aussi
pour vous,
pour les futurs,
car quand on va
croiser les problèmes
entre Caïm et Abel,
ils avaient déjà
des paramètres
pour savoir
quel type
d'adoration
pourrait véritablement
plaire Dieu.
Donc voilà pourquoi
les fruits
n'étaient pas suffisants,
les versements
du sang
étaient nécessaires
pour que
nous puissions
nous approcher
des dieux
avec la conscience
qu'on méritait
plutôt souffrir,
mais Dieu
a promis
et la méthode
des dieux
de nous couvrir
de ses péchés,
c'était véritablement
par la peau
d'animaux.
Et donc ces animaux-là,
c'est déjà
des nuances
envers l'agneau
pascal
et tous les
lommages
dans sa direction,
mais c'était déjà
cette notion
que Dieu va
dévier temporairement
sa colère
de nous
envers
les types
du Christ
jusqu'au jour
qui Christ
arriverait
pour lui
vraiment
recevoir sur lui
la punition
de nos péchés
et nous
revêtir
de sa durature.
Et donc là,
on voit
Dieu a fait
des habits
des peaux
et il les a
revêtis.
L'éternel Dieu
dit
voici l'homme
est devenu
comme l'un de nous
pour la connaissance
du bien
et du mal,
empêchons-le
maintenant
d'avancer
sa mort
et de prendre
de l'arbre
de la vie,
d'en manger
et de vivre
éternellement.
Donc ici,
une lecture superficielle
pense que ça fait
encore partie
quai des condamnations,
la privation
de rendre
notre condition éternelle,
mais c'était
surtout en signe
des grâces.
C'est un Dieu
qui nous empêche,
donc il y a
tous les langages aussi,
donc pour ceux
qui étudient
la théologie biblique,
c'est très important
car chacun
de ces éléments
sont développés
en ce qu'on appelle
dans la théologie biblique
des narratives particulières
qui enrichissent
notre compréhension
du Christ.
Donc tous les langages,
par exemple,
dépôt des animaux,
de la substitution
car Dieu va apaiser
sa colère temporairement
par les sens versés
des animaux
pour une didatique
envers nous.
Il y a ces langages
de la sémence,
la dispute
entre la descendance
du serpent
et du descendant
de la femme
et il y a aussi
cette notion
de l'arbre,
l'arbre de la vie,
donc les Christ
qui va être
les vrais fruits
qui peuvent
véritablement nous nourrir,
qui peuvent nous donner
la vie éternelle
et qui est pendu
dans un bois,
dans un arbre.
Il y a tous ces langages
de l'arbre aussi
qui sera très récourant
dans la Bible
et donc ça peut enrichir
aussi notre perspective
de la théologie biblique
à plusieurs regards.
Mais là,
cet arbre-là
qui représentait
la récompense
s'ils étaient obéissants,
c'était pour rendre
leur état parfait
encore plus parfait
et éternel,
plus passible
des chutes.
Et c'est là
que c'est à restaurer
un Christ
et lorsqu'on arrivera
à la gloire,
il y aura
l'arbre du fruit
de la vie,
de la vie éternelle
qui nous pourrons
manger.
Donc quelque part,
c'est la représentation
du Christ lui-même
mais c'est un empêchement
qui a une mesure
des grâces.
Donc c'est pour dire
ils ne vont pas
prendre de l'arbre
de la vie
pour ne pas rendre
leur condition pécheresse
définitive,
éternelle.
OK ?
Et en même temps,
ils seront chassés
de cette église parfaite
qui était l'église originale.
Donc on se rappelle très bien
les jardins d'Édans,
c'était comme un sanctuaire,
il était comme une église.
On a été créés
en dehors de l'Édans
et on a été insérés
par la grâce des dieux
au dédans de l'Édans.
Et à partir de là,
on a été privés.
Donc là, verset 23,
l'éternel Dieu
les chassa du jardin d'Édans
pour qu'il cultiva la terre
d'où il avait été pris.
OK ?
Donc c'est cette manifestation
de cette punition,
de cet égarment,
de cet chassement
car on a perdu
notre condition
des perfections originales
et qui nous empêchent
d'avoir cette proximité
des dieux.
Donc à partir de là,
toute approche des dieux
aura besoin des médiations
quelque part
jusqu'à ce que les vrais médiateurs
aient lieu.
OK ?
Et donc à partir de là,
on a déjà une base
didatique
pour comprendre
les sacrifices
qu'on doit présenter
pour nous approcher
des dieux.
Il y a cette notion
des distances envers Dieu
mais tous les jugements
ont été aussi
dilués par la grâce
des dieux
car ces choses
auraient pu avoir lieu
de manière définitive
et immédiate
tout de suite.
Et Dieu,
par sa grâce
sur la base
de sa promesse,
va étendre
sa patience
afin de développer
les plans
des rédemptions.
Et donc à partir de là,
on voit aussi
qu'il chassa
Adam
et il mit
à l'orient
du jardin
des dents
les chérubins
qui agitent
une épée flamboyante
pour garder
l'échemin
de l'arbre
de la vie.
Et donc ici,
c'est aussi glorieux
et je pense
que nous sommes privilégés
surtout ceux
qui ont été
là depuis le départ,
qui n'ont pas raté
les séances
quand on a considéré
la création des dieux
et qu'on a considéré
les anges
car c'est une doctrine
qu'on n'enseigne pas
très souvent
et malheureusement,
il y a très
concentré
à voir
des révélations
des anges,
etc.,
sans avoir
une connaissance
biblique
de la doctrine
sur les anges.
Et donc les anges,
je vous rappelle,
ils sont aussi
organisés
en rangs,
il y a plusieurs rangs
d'importance
entre les anges
et certains anges
ont un rôle
particulier
vis-à-vis
à d'autres.
Et les chérubins
sont d'entre
ceux qui sont
les plus privilégiés,
qui réjouissent
d'une proximité
encore plus particulière
de la présence
du trône des dieux,
de la gloire des dieux.
Et des fois,
ils sont décrits
dans la Bible
comme en ayant
des formes variables,
donc certains
avec la représentation
des animaux
ou de l'humanité.
Et donc,
selon certains théologiens,
et j'ai partagé
cet avis,
ils représentent
quelque part,
symboliquement,
typologiquement,
tout l'univers,
toute l'humanité
et toute la création
restaurée.
C'est déjà
les êtres
qui ont été créés
pour typifier
cet espoir
de restauration
de toute la création
et de l'humanité.
Donc voilà pourquoi
les quatre qui sont là
autour du trône des dieux
ont cette description
et ces anges en particulier,
ces séraphins
qui ont été placés
à cet endroit,
ces chérubins,
ils avaient une épée
flamboyante
qui semble communiquer
une totale interdition.
Donc tous les langages
de l'Arche de l'Alliance
doivent être évoqués là,
donc on se rappelle,
deux chérubins
sur l'Arche
et des moments
dans l'histoire d'Israël
où certains hommes
avec des bonnes motivations
ont essayé
de toucher l'Arche
et qu'ils étaient foudroyés.
Et donc cette représentation
de l'Arche
de revenir à la présence
des dieux,
de revenir au sanctuaire,
à cette intimité
qui ne pouvait pas
être prise à la légère
sans la considération
qu'on puisse arriver
au 100 décembre.
Vous vous rappelez
de la plante,
on dit plante,
non,
les plants
de tabernacle,
oui,
il y avait l'attriant,
ok,
où nous,
on pouvait apporter
nos sacrifices
et qui étaient brûlés
à l'extérieur.
Il y avait
les 100 lieux
qui représentaient
une proximité
encore plus grande
comme si c'était
la maison
et la chambre
d'intimité des dieux
qui représentait
les 100 décents.
Et personne
ne pouvait y arriver
à part les suprêmes
sacrificateurs
une fois par an,
ok,
pour s'approcher.
Il y avait
toutes les règles
pour les transports.
Mais la représentation
c'était cette approche,
cette intimité
envers Dieu
et tous les éléments
qui représentaient
les besoins absolus
du Christ
dans son sacrifice
et dans son intercession.
Et donc à partir
de là,
quand on pense
de quelle manière
cette présence
des dieux
est protégée
pour que nous,
les impurs,
on ne s'approche pas
des lettres
si sains
pour que nous,
on ne soit pas
foudroyés,
c'est pour notre protection,
on n'ose pas
s'approcher
à la légère
et donc on voit
de manière très claire
ici déjà
cet aspect
des épées flamboyantes
d'un côté
et en même temps
ce qu'ils représentaient,
c'est comme s'ils disaient
il y a encore
un espoir pour vous,
vous allez
réveillir
et être glorifiés
pour pouvoir
accéder à ces jardins
ou à ceux
que ces jardins représentent,
mais pas encore.
Donc c'est un mixte
de jugements
éminents,
certains
et une glorification
par les moyens
qui dure à pouvoir.
Donc déjà,
en Genèse,
nous voyons
toute cette richesse
qui, bien sûr,
par une révélation progressive,
ce n'était pas
très clair.
Voilà pourquoi
l'apôtre Paul,
qui je crois
être l'auteur d'Hébreu,
il dit
que
je ne sais même pas
si c'est plutôt Pierre,
bon,
je vais avoir les textes après,
mais qui nous disent
en fait que
même les prophètes
qui sont venus
avant nous,
ils ont désiré,
ils ont aspiré
à avoir la connaissance
que nous pouvons avoir.
L'Écriture lui-même,
il dit la même chose.
Et la réalité,
c'est qu'en ayant
la révélation
du Nouveau Testament,
nous sommes beaucoup
plus équipés
à comprendre
l'Ancien Testament
qu'il y a les privilèges
qu'ils ont eus
par ces révélations
dont ils pouvaient
comprendre et saisir
les principales,
mais encore
de manière obscure,
pas en pleine lumière.
Donc voilà
comment c'est important
de conclure
cette portion
des considérations
des expositions
par rapport
au péché
original
et la chute
avec la considération
aussi
de l'évangile prêché,
de l'espoir
qui était là
dès le départ.
Et donc,
nous allons
nous introduire maintenant
dans la considération
doctrinale,
nous allons revenir
à la confession de foi
et je pense qu'on est déjà
beaucoup plus équipés
lorsque nous allons lire
la confession de foi,
nous serons plus équipés
à comprendre en fait
les terminologies
qu'ils utilisent
en apportant une notion
plus structurée
vis-à-vis la doctrine.
Donc,
si vous avez
votre confession
avec vous,
nous avons cet abordage
et cette suturation
de la confession de foi
et mon objectif
sera
de traverser
la confession de foi
en mettant en phase
certains termes
ou expressions théologiques
qui sont très importantes
pour nous
de comprendre.
Donc,
ce sont des efforts
que les théologiens
ont fait
pour expliquer
ou classifier
les vérités principales
et parfois
quelques conceptions
qui provoquent
un peu
des difficultés
de compréhension
mais qui sont importantes
pour nous
de saisir.
Et donc,
nous pouvons considérer
les premiers paragraphes
donc si quelqu'un peut lire
donc les premiers paragraphes
il est consacré
à expliquer
la nature
de la chute
ou l'origine
du péché.
Il décrit
les scénarios
généraux
du péché
ou de la chute
et aussi
les étapes
de la chute.
Et je pense
qu'en lisant maintenant
il y a beaucoup de choses
qui seront évoquées
à vos esprits
par toutes les expositions
qu'on a faites
des textes bibliques.
Donc,
bien que Dieu
ait créé l'homme
droit
et parfait
donc là
ça nous renvoie
à la première expression
qu'on a faite
sur l'état
béatifique
original
et lui a donné
une loi juste
donc là
non seulement
l'homme
obéissait
de manière
automatique
et naturelle
mais Dieu
a établi
ses pactes
originels
par rapport
aux arbres
et là
Dieu lui a donné
une loi
juste
qui était
en vue
de la vie
s'il l'avait
observée
et qu'il avait
menacée
des morts
s'il la transgressait
et donc là
on doit observer
déjà
l'intégrité
originale
la susceptibilité
à échouer
ou à
quelque part
développer
davantage
leurs conditions
et
les menaces
qui ont été placées
et récompenses
qui ont été
communiquées
et donc
il y a cet aspect
des susceptibilités
et il y a aussi
la notion
de temporalité
l'homme n'a pas gardé
longtemps
cet honneur
donc Dieu avait établi
en temps
pour ces tests
voilà pourquoi
Dieu a donné
la récompense
c'est une évidence
très claire
manger de l'arbre
du fruit
de l'arbre de la vie
ça signifiait
qu'il y avait
un moment
il y avait un terme
pour finir
ces tests
ou ces pactes
cette opportunité
des soumissions volontaires
mais où
nous on a choisi
l'autonomie
créer nos propres lois
ne pas nous soumettre
à la loi des dieux
et donc là
l'homme n'a pas gardé
longtemps
cet honneur
utilisant subtilement
les serpents
et là
ça commence à décrire
les étapes
ok
Satan
donc là
à nouveau
c'est une question
confessionnelle
si nous nous affirmons
une église
confessionnelle
historique
si nous voulons
nous protéger
des hérésies
qui ont été commises
au long de l'histoire
c'est très bien
de nous trouver
en harmonie
avec les confessions
c'est pas pour dire
que les confessions
sont inspirées
mais c'est pour dire
que quand on cherche
un fil doré
dans l'histoire
de l'église
et faire la distinction
entre ceux
qui se sont déviés
envers plusieurs hérésies
nous devons tous
affronter ensemble
qui est quelque part
l'endroit
le plus sécurisé
historiquement
contre les hérésies
c'est
sous les parapluies
des crédeaux
ok
orthodoxes
conservateurs
et des confessions
des fois
et donc nous
surtout les réformés
on n'a pas cherché
à porter des innovations
en termes
des confessions
des fois
on a cherché
à revenir
aux bases
historiques
de la foi
et donc ici
nous sommes devant
une question confessionnelle
un abordage littéral
du serpent
donc utilisant
subtilement
les serpents
la confession
ne laisse pas
ouverte
la possibilité
d'une interprétation
symbolique
mythologique
du serpent
les rédacteurs
des confessions
ils étaient intentionnels
pour laisser
de manière très claire
que cette interprétation
littérale
est importante
la biblique
et donc
utilisant
subtilement
le serpent
Satan
séduisit
Ève
et par elle
il séduisit
Adam
qui s'encontrante
sur lui
transgressa
volontairement
la loi
de leur créateur
et les commandements
qui leur avaient été donnés
en mangeant du fruit
défendu
et donc là
c'est
voilà
c'est juste
de faire écho
au récit biblique
de manière littérale
ok
et donc
il y a
une explication
biblique
car ça c'est une question
importante pour nous
c'est un mystère
pour nous
comment des êtres
humains
qui ont été créés
parfaitement
ont pu arriver
à point
de commettre
cette corruption
les mystères
de savoir
quand est-ce que
un désir légitime
devient un péché
dans leur cœur
on n'a pas accès
mais c'est
que la Bible
laisse très clair
pour nous
c'est que
l'influence
et la séduction
du serpent
était importante
et le fait
qu'Adam
a reçu
cette loi
des dieux
avant Ève
ça donne aussi
des indices
par rapport
à la susceptibilité
d'Ève
en tout cas
c'est surtout
Adam lui-même
qui s'est rappelé
directement par Dieu
car
les pactes
ont été établis
avec les représentants
ou les chefs
de l'humanité
et donc à partir de là
c'est lui
qui est les premiers
appelés
pour rendre compte
et donc
les jugements
qui tombent
sur l'humanité
à nouveau
il y a des moments
où Adam
est appelé
tout simplement
homme
mais quand on est
devant ces passages
on est devant Adam
qui veut dire
humanité plutôt
et donc là
on est devant
les représentants
de toute l'humanité
et donc
au lieu de protéger
sa femme
d'exercer son rôle
de mari
ok
il a subi
à sa tentation
et voilà
il transgressa
volontairement
la loi
de leur créateur
et donc là
on voit
qu'il n'y a
aucune excuse
malgré
la séduction
et la solidarité
donc la responsabilisation
reste là
et les commandements
qui leur avaient été donnés
en mangeant
du fruit défendu
il a plus
à Dieu
et donc là
c'est une autre
problématique
qu'on fait face
quand on traite
la question
de la chute
ok
donc il y a
la problématique
les premiers grands mystères
comment
les péchés
vont naître
dans le cœur
d'un instrument parfait
ok
la deuxième question
c'est
comment
un Dieu
souverain
sage
et parfait
peut permettre
ces types de choses
et donc ça nous renvoie
et voilà les privilèges
de suivre
toutes les études
et l'ordre des études
des confessions
des fois
quand on a traité
la question
de la souveraineté
des dieux
et la question
de la providence
des dieux
des décrets
éternels des dieux
on a appris
à considérer
que par exemple
la gouvernance
souveraine divine
elle ne supprime pas
la réalité
des moyens
secondaires
c'est ce qu'on appelle
la concurrence
des agents libres
qui sont les êtres humains
et donc nous sommes
c'est une réalité
biblique
nous sommes les
responsables
directes
des mauvaises actions
des mauvaises décisions
des péchés
et Dieu n'est jamais
l'auteur du mal
et Dieu dans sa souveraineté
il a créé les mondes
d'une telle manière
qu'il a la capacité
de justifier
ce que ses plans
sages
ont décidé
il a cette liberté
en tant que créateur
il n'est jamais
l'auteur du mal
il n'est tant personne
mais il fait
cette gouvernance
glorieuse
afin de converger
les mâles ambiants
et les choses
qui sont
sous sa permission
ont un but
d'accomplissement
encore plus élevé
qu'il apporte
par sa justice
par sa sagesse
donc il a plus à Dieu
de permettre
cette chute
dans son conseil sage
et sans
puisqu'il avait déterminé
de l'utiliser
pour manifester
sa gloire
deuxième point
tiens 11
et c'est toi
toutefois
de même
que les péchés
pardon
de même
que les serpents
séduisées
elle
par sa ruse
je crois
que vos pensées
ne se corrompent pas
mais se détournant
de la simplicité
à l'égard
du Christ
Genèse 3
l'homme répondit
la femme
qui tu as mise
auprès de moi
m'a donné l'arbre
et j'ai mangé
et l'éternel Dieu
dit à la femme
pourquoi tu as fait cela
la femme répondit
c'est la serpente
qui m'a séduisie
Genèse 2
l'éternel Dieu
donna cet ordre
à l'homme
tu pourras manger
de tous les arbres
du jardin
mais tu ne mangeras
pas de l'arbre
de la connaissance
du bien et du mal
car les jours
où tu mangeras
tu mourras
donc à ces jours-là
ils sont morts
radicalement
mais pas
totalement immédiatement
ok
et donc voilà
quelques textes bibliques
qui supportent
ces premiers paragraphes
donc les premiers paragraphes
je pense que c'est
le plus facile
à assimiler
après toutes les expositions
qu'on a fait
car c'est plutôt
un écho
de la description
biblique de la chute
les deuxièmes paragraphes
ça commence
à insérer
des conceptions
doctrinales
plus importantes
donc voilà
par ces péchés
nos premiers parents
ont perdu
leur justice
originelle
et leur communion
avec Dieu
et nous
en eux
et c'est fait
la mort
est venue
sur tous
tous sont devenus
morts
dans les péchés
et entièrement
suyés
dans toutes les facultés
et les parties
de leur âme
et de leur corps
quels sont
en fait
les concepts
doctrinaires
doctrinaux
pardon
qui vous identifiez
dans ces paragraphes
pour les
théologiens
entre nous
juste pour
aller dans la direction
des terminologies
plus théologiques
le fédéralisme
donc qu'est-ce que
cela veut dire
Nat
c'est le fait
d'avoir un représentant
pour un groupe
ok
les péchés
par représentation
la dépravation totale
dans quelle portion
de texte
tu trouves ça
ok
dans toutes les facultés
la dépravation totale
pour la conception
de cette bataille
contre les
arméniens
qu'on a
qu'on a eu
par
les synodes
de Dordech
on dit ça
comme ça en français
Dordech
donc c'est de là
qu'on va avoir
cette conception
du tulipe
ok
les cinq points
vers lesquels
il y a eu
des divergences
des arméniens
vers les réformés
et à partir de là
c'est pas
pour réduire
à cinq points
la conception réformée
c'est juste
les cinq points
qui ont été
les plus sous-attaque
et donc la réaction
des réformés
était
de mettre
l'emphase biblique
sur ces points
et donc
les premiers points
c'est la
totale
dépravation
et elle se trouve
enracinée
déjà dans les récits
des jeunesses
et renforcée
en Romain
chapitre 5
et donc
ok
donc dépravation totale
est-ce que vous voyez
encore d'autres
ou
voilà
la doctrine
de péché original
donc super
pour l'instant
c'est super
je vais revenir
sur ces termes
ces expressions
mais bon
du paragraphe 2
au paragraphe 5
nous sommes concentrés
sur les résultats
de la chute
et les paragraphes 2
et 3
ils nous parlent
sur la solidarité
du péché
c'est-à-dire
de quelle manière
nous participons
au péché
original
d'Adam
ok
et donc
déjà
il y a cette notion
au paragraphe 2
du péché
des représentations
ok
par ces péchés
nos premiers parents
ont perdu
leur justice originelle
et leur communion
avec Dieu
et nous
en eux
ok
et donc
c'est nous en eux
c'est un mystère
aussi pour nous
car
il y aura
certains
qui vont se porter
plus sur la notion
d'une participation
effective
dans leur nature
c'est-à-dire
comme toute l'humanité
est descendante
d'Adam et Ève
nous pensons
que comme ils ont
perdu
cette justice originale
comme ils ont été
corrompus
et coupés
de cette communion
avec Dieu
nous pensons
que tout simplement
de manière automatique
comme nous sommes
ses descendants
c'est la réalité
pour toute l'humanité
et
quand on pense
à la notion
des transmissions
de la corruption
et de la pollution
il faut qu'on soit d'accord
donc c'est un mystère
pour nous
d'affirmer avec certitude
de quelle manière
la corruption
d'Adam
à partir du moment
il a perdu
sa condition
des perfections originales
qu'il n'allait pas mourir
!
sa santé physique
parfaite
et surtout
son caractère moral
parfait
donc de quelle manière
ces choses
passent envers nous
car nous
pouvons comprendre
de quelle manière
nos maladies génétiques
peuvent passer
avec nos enfants
mais la question
de l'âme
lorsque la Bible
décrit les sièges
de péché
comme en étant
dans l'esprit
dans l'âme
dans les cœurs
comment comprendre
en fait
qu'on pourrait
avoir cette
transmission
ça renvoie
à la notion
de comment
les âmes sont générées
car si elles sont
spontanément générées
par Dieu directement
quelque part
Dieu serait en train
d'insérer la corruption
au moment
il était en train
de créer une nouvelle âme
c'est un mystère
il y a un problème grave
mais si on pense
que c'est
l'âme tout simplement
qui passe
des parents
à enfants
c'est aussi un mystère
car c'est une notion
un peu matérialisée
de l'âme
vous comprenez
et donc nous devons
savoir reconnaître
quelles sont nos limites
on a quand même
un indice
lorsqu'il Christ
vient
en tant
qu'être
humain
incarné
nous savons
que
quelque part
il a pris
la nature
d'Ève
ok
et en même temps
pardon
la nature
de Marie
quelque part
engendrée
véritablement
dans les ventres
de Marie
et en même temps
le fait
qu'elle ne soit
pas encore
qu'elle n'ait pas
encore eu
des relations
qu'elle soit
vierge
c'était nécessaire
et il nous semble
que cette nécessité
c'est pour préserver
Christ
de cette corruption
peut-être que la circoncision
donne aussi un indice
dans sa direction
ce sont des conjectures
car ça met l'emphase
que la corruption
vient dès la jeunesse
dès la sémence
de l'homme
quelque part
et ça nous renvoie
à d'un ton chef
donc pour considérer
de quelle manière
la corruption
a été transmise
nous pouvons penser
de manière légitime
car il y a des passages
comme Hebreu
qui nous disent
que Lévi
il était déjà
en train de donner
la dîme
en Abraham
et nous savons
que toute l'humanité
était en Adam
de manière effective
nous sommes tous
descendants d'Adam
et donc par rapport
à la transmission
de la corruption
il nous semble
qu'il y a une transmission
naturelle
par contre
nous ne sommes pas
responsabilisés
selon la Bible
ou coupabilisés
qu'est par cette notion
de transmission
ou les péchés
effectifs
ou la corruption
réelle
que nous avons
une fois qu'on est
déjà dans l'iniquité
sauf que la Bible
elle met beaucoup
d'enfaith
sur le fait
que nous participons
à la coupabilité
d'Adam
car il était
notre représentant
légal
donc la manière
la plus explicite
de la Bible
de les présenter
s'est trouvée
en Romain 5
et cette manière
de représenter
cette réalité
est une manière
qui va être
tellement explicite
par rapport
à notre participation
effective
par représentation
d'Adam
devant ses pactes
avec Dieu
qui marche
dans la même direction
dans la représentation
du Christ
en tant que
notre
justificateur
c'est-à-dire
si la coupabilité
de l'humanité
et ses conséquences
ne se trouvent pas
enracinées
surtout par la
représentation légale
d'Adam
devant Dieu
notre justification
les pardons
de nos péchés
ne peuvent pas
se trouver
non plus
en Christ
par amputation
amputation
c'est une notion
où sa coupabilité
est amputée
envers tous ceux
qui étaient représentés
est considérée
comme une coupabilité
de toute la race
car il était
les représentants
de toute la race
et en même temps
Christ représentant
de la nouvelle création
il peut amputer
sa justice
envers tous ceux
qui vont l'embrasser
par la foi
en tant que son représentant
donc pour les plus
résistants d'entre nous
avec les crises
que nous avons tous
par rapport
à la justice
totale des dieux
par rapport à tout ça
la réalité
c'est que si
nous résistons
à accepter
ce qui est
bibliquement explicite
car la Bible
ne nous donne pas
la possibilité
de ne pas faire face
à cette réalité
de cette manière
car tous les textes
bibliques sont
explicites
c'est-à-dire
on n'a pas le droit
d'avoir une interprétation
biblique
divergente
de cette représentation
fédérale
d'Adam
et du fait
que cette coupabilité
et ses conséquences
nous touchent
car ils nous représentaient
légalement
devant Dieu
nous pouvons avoir
des crises
et c'est
notre faute
c'est notre incapacité
de saisir les choses
mais la réalité
c'est que la foi
elle nous conduit
dans la direction
d'embrasser
joyeusement
cette suture
cette relation
déjà
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui a choisi
Adam
en tant que représentant
donc on ne peut pas
considérer
qu'on aurait pu choisir
quelqu'un mieux que lui
on ne peut jamais
conjecturer
qu'on aurait pu
être mieux
qu'Adam
pour nous en sortir
mieux que lui
devant cette tentation
ok
et la réalité
c'est que
de toute manière
c'est la manière
dont Dieu
les 100 des 100
à formaliser les choses
et c'est
quelque chose
d'inévitable
quelque part
car la Bible
nous enseigne
de manière pratique
de manière très claire
de comment
l'influence
de ceux qui sont
en position
de représentation
exerce des impacts
envers ceux
qui sont
ces représentés
donc par exemple
on n'a même pas
les choix
internationaux
à partir du moment
où on a élu
quelque part
avec toutes nos imperfections
des leaders
et s'ils prennent
des décisions
internationales
importantes
et qu'ils rentrent
en guerre
nous allons tous
souffrir
les conséquences
de ces décisions
et la réalité
c'est qu'Adam
était là
en tant que notre
représentant
fédéral
et donc ici
au paragraphe 2
par ses péchés
nos premiers parents
ont perdu
leur justice
originelle
et leur communion
avec Dieu
et nous en eux
des faits
des effets
pardon
la mort
est venue
sur tous
donc il y a
des églises
qui font
des démarches
qui cherchent
on va dire
à casser
des liens
hérésitaires
etc
il y a des passages
bibliques
où Dieu
prononce
un jugement
qui peut passer
des générations
en générations
mais dans
ces mêmes passages
bibliques
sont en phase
plus grande
c'est
l'emphase
de parler
de sa générosité
à pardonner
sa miséricorde
qui s'est renouvelée
encore plus
des générations
beaucoup plus
et donc
le texte
il est clair
et on peut
comprendre ça
de manière
qui ne se porte
pas à mon avis
par une question
des représentations
c'est qu'on est
en train de traiter
en jeunesse
mais qui se porte
dans la réalité
des faits
si vous voulez
garder mon alliance
par ces privilèges
que j'établis
avec vous
voilà
vous allez
réjouir
des conséquences
et donc
il y a plusieurs
explications
pour ça
donc il y a
la justice
des dieux
il y a
la notion
des représentations
un peu plus
faibles
dans ces contextes
mais la notion
de l'observation
naturelle des choses
en général
un homme très
impi
aura cette influence
envers ses enfants
qui vont suivre
ses péchés
et c'est comme ça
qu'on voit les jugements
dans la bible
quand ça a lieu
en fait
les jugements
qui retombent
sur les enfants
des enfants
par contre
à partir du moment
où on voit
une personne
véritablement répentante
qui ne veut pas suivre
l'échément
de ses parents
etc
il n'y a pas
de continuité
par rapport à ça
donc il faut
qu'on soit très conscient
en fait
même aujourd'hui
après la conversion
il y a encore
les restes
de notre éducation
contre lesquels
on doit lutter
en fait
mais l'évangile
il est puissant
pour vaincre tout ça
sans qu'on ait besoin
de faire des démarches
des chambres
de guérison
ou d'autres méthodologies
la réalité
c'est que c'est très récent
dans l'église
de mettre l'emphase
sur ces choses
et c'est notamment
à partir du contact
avec la psychanalyse moderne
donc c'est plutôt
un vernis évangélique
qui ont embrassé
ces procédures
psychanalytiques
où on essaye
de visiter
les passés
de la personne
pour chercher
à trouver
des explications
dans des traumas
d'enfance
du pourquoi
la personne vit ça
et bien sûr
dans les milieux
très charismatiques
ça va gagner
encore plus
en vernis
des malédictions
héréditaires
avec la notion
des batailles spirituelles
etc
mais nous ne trouvons pas
des basubles pour ça
donc on a des passages
très explicites
où Dieu dit
car les pères
ont mangé
des
comment on dit
en français
des raisins pourris
les dents
de ces enfants
seront
agacées
et donc Dieu dit
expressement
non
chacun
s'est révéliable
par rapport
à ses propres péchés
donc il y a
cette notion
d'influence
bien sûr
qu'il y a aussi
toute la dynamique
spirituelle
surtout pour
les plus paillants
donc c'est évident
dans des familles
qui ont
des rapports
animistes
envers la religion
etc
qu'il y a
une oppression
qui peut perdurer
au sein de la famille
envers ses enfants
etc
donc ce sont des choses
qu'on a cultivées
envers la mort
et qu'on va raconter
par contre
à partir du moment
où Dieu rentre
dans l'histoire
pour sauver quelqu'un
pour ceux qui sont
Christ
nouvelle créature
toutes les choses
ont été faites
nouvelles
il n'y a plus
aucune chose
qui va rester
en termes
des malédictions
ok
donc à partir
du moment
où il était
fait
en fin des jours
on a passé
de l'empire
des ténèbres
au royaume
de sa merveilleuse
lumière
et c'est impossible
de considérer
bien sûr
que les chrétiens
seront encore attaqués
on a la bataille
spirituelle
qui est constante
mais à partir
du moment
où la conversion
a lieu
tout est cassé
il n'y a aucune force
plus forte
que moi-même
en Christ
plus forte
que Christ
en moi
qui puisse m'empêcher
en fait
de surmonter
un péché spécifique
ou une bataille
spirituelle
particulière
donc là
c'est pas forcément
une hérésie
qui a été développée
à mon avis
de fédéralisme
biblique
mais c'est plutôt
une notion
qui a été plus
sous l'influence
des religions animistes
couplées
à ces méthodes
de traitement
de la psychanalyse
moderne
car c'est très récent
de voir cette emphase
dans les églises
de nos jours
donc juste pour conclure
avec cette notion
de la fédéralisation
du péché original
avant de passer
dans une prochaine étape
dans la scène prochaine
à la nature
du péché
en soi-même
donc
il y a
trois aspects
lorsqu'on dit
les péchés
originales
il y a trois aspects
par rapport
à cette notion
d'originalité
et donc
c'est
notamment
le premier aspect
c'est d'être
véritablement lié
au premier péché
au péché original
ok
c'est-à-dire
c'est Adam
lorsqu'il a péché
car il était
le représentant
de toute l'humanité
donc par représentation
nous sommes tous
coupables
et nous sommes tous
corrompus
à cause du péché
qu'il a commis
ok
cette notion
de coupabilité
qui portera
ces conséquences
elle est enracinée
dans cette représentation
fédérale
d'Adam
ok
et cette notion
des corruptions
elle a lieu
en nous
à cause
de ces premiers péchés
fédérale
d'Adam
mais
il nous semble
que la transmission
elle est
communiquée
de manière
aussi
à cause du fait
que nous étions
en lui
en tant que nature
en tant qu'humanité
d'accord
et donc
il a cette notion
du siège
aussi au niveau du cœur
donc c'est la
c'est la deuxième notion
quand on parle
du péché original
c'est pour nous rappeler
que les péchés
à son siège
au cœur
ou à la source
de l'être humain
voilà pourquoi
on parle de la dépravation
totale
il va toucher
à toutes les facultés
pourquoi les péchés
vont toucher
à toutes les facultés
c'est car les péchés
à son siège
dans la source
de l'être
on peut penser
à cette tridimension
de la spiritualité
ou la tridimension
qui est l'être humain
la trichotomie
si vous voulez
et donc on pense
que l'être humain
il a une portion
matérielle
du corps
et une portion
spirituelle
immatérielle
et donc cette portion
matérielle
elle est décrite
parfois
comme synonyme
âme et esprit
mais parfois
il y a une légère
distinction
où l'âme
veut représenter
ce qu'on garde
même après les péchés
et la chute
et l'esprit
c'est ce qui nous connectait
à Dieu directement
et c'est la réalité
d'être spirituellement
mort
et donc des fois
nous sommes tentés
à nous laisser
gouverner plutôt
par les tentations
de la chair
et là on parle
plutôt de cette nature
corrompue
qui porte
son effet
envers
les désirs
charnels du corps
ou les désirs
même charnels
dans l'essence
spirituelle
des lames
les péchés
d'orgueil
d'intellectualisme
d'arrogance
d'envie
etc
ou les péchés
tout simplement
voilà
de l'immoralité
sexuelle
ou
glutonnerie
etc
donc l'être humain
il est un complète
désordre
en désintégration
car depuis
la source
il a été corrompu
c'est à cause du coeur
la source
de l'être
que nous trouvons
la corruption
et ça va tâcher
toutes nos facultés
on a encore
la capacité
de raisonner
on a encore
la capacité
de manifester
une mesure
de l'image
des dieux
chez l'être humain
mais l'incapacité
avant la conversion
de gouverner
nos passions
qu'elles se portent
envers les corps
ou qu'elles se portent
envers les pensées
ou les émotions
c'est car
notre esprit est mort
nous sommes spirituellement
morts
ok
et donc voilà pourquoi
la bible
elle va parler
du péché original
non seulement
pour nous connecter
au péché premier
d'Adam
mais nous rappeler
que dans l'origine
de l'être
nous sommes corrompus
de la source
et une autre chose
que cela veut dire
c'est que nous sommes nés
en iniquité
donc depuis l'origine
de l'humanité
à partir du moment
où on est né
on est conçu
en iniquité
et nous sommes nés
donc la réalité
c'est qu'on n'a pas
cette idée romantique
qui est l'être humain
est une table rase
et qui selon
la corruption du milieu
il va développer
des habitudes
corrompues
non
nos enfants
ils sont déjà
avec la coupabilité
du péché
et avec la corruption
ou la pollution
du péché
et donc nous
ne sommes pas
en train de commettre
des actes
nous ne sommes pas
considérés pécheurs
car nous sommes en train
de commettre
des actes du péché
nous sommes en train
de commettre
et nous ne pouvons pas
nous empêcher
de commettre
des péchés
en actes
en pensée
ou dans nos affections
car nous sommes
dans une condition
pécheresse
ok
on va s'arrêter
ici aujourd'hui
en ayant défini
la notion
du péché
original
et nous allons
donc revenir
à cette considération
je voulais lire
juste
romans 5
12 à 19
pour conclure
si vous voulez
me suivre
c'est pourquoi
comme par un seul homme
les péchés
sont entrés
dans les mondes
et par les péchés
la mort
et qu'ainsi
est étendue
sur tous les hommes
parce qu'ils
sont tous
ont péché
car jusqu'à la loi
les péchés
étaient dans les mondes
or les péchés
n'est pas
imputés
lorsqu'il n'a
point des lois
c'est pendant
la mort
a régné
depuis Adam
jusqu'à Moïse
même sur ceux
qui n'avaient pas péché
par une transgression
semblable
à celle d'Adam
c'est très important
même si
c'est pas
car on a commis
des péchés
comme Adam
c'est car on était
un Adam
ou car Adam
nous représentait
lesquels
sont la figure
de celui
qui devait venir
mais il n'en est pas
du don
comme de la faute
car si plusieurs
ont péri
par la faute
d'un seul
combien plus
la grâce
des dieux
et les dons
par la grâce
d'un seul
homme
Jésus Christ
ont-ils abondé
pour plusieurs
et il n'est
pas du
pardon
il n'est pas du don
comme de ce qui est arrivé
par un seul
qui a péché
car les jugements
a été par un seul
pour la condamnation
vous voyez
la coupabilité
la condamnation
nous a touchés aussi
à tous
même si on était là
avec Adam
mais les dons
de la grâce
a été par plusieurs
fautes
pour la justification
donc c'est important
aussi de remarquer
la différence
des langages
entre l'universalité
de la condamnation
Adam
et la particularité
donc un autre point
des cinq points
de Calvinisme
donc l'expiation
définie
ok
et donc là
on va être très clair
les langages
ont plusieurs fautes
pour la justification
par un universalisme
envers les saluts
si par la faute d'un seul
la mort a régné
par lui seul
combien plus ceux
qui reçoivent
l'abondance
de la grâce
et du don
de la justice
régneront
dans la vie
par Jésus Christ
lui seul
il est donc
comme par un seul acte
de justice
pour tous les hommes
en justification
des vies
car comme par la désobéissance
d'un seul
d'un seul homme
beaucoup ont été rendus
pécheurs
dès même par l'obéissance
d'un seul
beaucoup seront rendus
justes
la loi est intervenue
pour que l'offense
fût multipliée
mais là où les péchés
abondaient
la grâce
a surabondé
afin que comme les péchés
araignés
dans la mort
dès même la grâce
règne par la justice
en vue de la vie éternelle
par Jésus Christ
notre Seigneur
Amen
oui
oui mon frère
est-ce qu'il y a eu
une liaison
entre
le passage
de
Esos
où
l'Éternel dit
à Moïse
je plénerai
le péché des paix
sur les enfants
jusqu'à la
troisième
quatrième génération
et
aussi
une relation
entre
ce passage là
et le péché
originaire
oui
à nouveau
je pense que là
c'est les rétablissements
dans un cadre
d'alliance
et c'était
une manière
de Dieu
de communiquer
ceux qui
casseraient
volontairement
l'alliance
déjà dans un cadre
d'une alliance
des grâces
quelles seraient
les conséquences
et dans les mêmes passages
on voit
qu'il va mettre
l'emphase
sur sa prédisposition
à la compassion
et aux miséricordes
jusqu'à mille générations
il faut voir
précisément
les textes
et donc
je ne crois pas
je crois que
l'élément
des représentativités
est présent
mais je pense
que les textes
se portent
plus
sur cet impact
et cette influence
qui inévitablement
seront présents
lorsqu'il
départ
s'est corrompt
etc
car
on voit
de manière très claire
comment Dieu
par sa grâce
à plusieurs reprises
peut sauver
des enfants
des hommes
qui étaient
très corrompus
par exemple
quand on pense
à Saúl
qui était très
corrompue
on voit déjà
son enfant
Jonathan
qui était
très béni
par Dieu
et donc
bien sûr
qu'il y aura
toujours des conséquences
et des mauvaises
conséquences
sur la vie
de ces personnes-là
mais qui ne
représentent pas
directement
cette indignation
des dieux
liées
aux fautes
de ses parents
et donc
là
à chaque fois
il faut
qu'on fasse
usage
de l'ensemble
des textes bibliques
qui touchent
un thème
et qu'on les interprète
de manière
à ne jamais
permettre
que la contradiction
ait lieu
et donc
il faut porter
une complémentarité
dans ces passages
pour qu'on n'arrive pas
à contredire
les écritures
avec les écritures
et donc
par exemple
le proverbe
c'est un langage
des vérités générales
par exemple
et donc
il y a plein
des dictons
bibliques
populaires
des règles
générales
de vie
qui sont
très généralisés
mais nous savons
qu'il y aura
toujours des exceptions
par rapport
à ces règles
et donc
c'est important
de voir
de quelle manière
l'emphase
des dieux
sur ces passages
c'était d'assurer
par exemple
comme on a vu
dans l'histoire
d'Israël
lorsque la majorité
était corrompue
et que les jugements
sont venus
sur Israël
comment même
les enfants
souffraient
avec les conséquences
des péchés
de leurs parents
et parfois
pour pourger
cette influence
corrompue
qui était généralisée
et systématisée
donc parfois
toute une génération
devrait mourir
ou même
plusieurs générations
jusqu'à ce que Dieu
donne une nouvelle
opportunité
pour Israël
donc je pense
Christophe
il a très bien
mis l'emphase
sur ces aspects
dans sa prédication
mais la réalité
c'est que
nous ne pouvons pas
interpréter
de manière
automatique
si jamais
on voit la possibilité
des personnes
qui se répentissent
véritablement
ok
car ça
c'est un complément
biblique aussi
comme les passages
qui ont été cités
aussi par rapport
aux raisons
mangers
etc
mais bon
les principes
des représentations
fédérales
il est un principe
qui va rester
partout
dans toute
réalité d'Israël
en ayant par exemple
des représentants
comme la période
des rois
la période
des juges
aussi même
et donc
nous voyons
de manière très claire
l'impact
des mauvais représentants
sur tous les peuples
mais
c'est clair
qu'il y a
deux représentants
pour l'humanité
de manière générale
c'est Christ
et Adam
et la Bible
est explicite
à cet égard
tous les autres
étaient des types
ou des médiateurs
qui pointaient
envers les Christ
mais les vrais
représentants fédéraux
de l'humanité
c'est Christ
et Adam